writers are taking steps following
protocols hoping they get a play to
legion stadium this season
the odds may be against the season but
the raiders are preparing with purpose
as kevin martin reports i think that's a
challenge
for the players to understand kind of
you know what's been provided here an
opportunity and don't take it for
granted you know it's
not like this everywhere eleven time pro
bowler jason whitton
knows that what the raiders have going
on here in vegas is special
and an opportunity he couldn't pass up i
mean it's just it's been first class
and that's been a good experience and
you know i'm coming from as you said
a kind of the maybe the leader of first
class and how you do it in the dallas
cowboys so i
had great experience there so there's a
buzz with that
during his tenure in dallas winton
became one of the most dominant tight
ends in the league
but now at 38 his role as a raider will
look much different
i think when you get to this age it's
all about the the fit
and the role and made a lot of sense for
him you know it's a
lot of really talented roster it's young
and
want to come in and be a veteran
presence for him another player the
raiders picked up and free agency former
chicago bear
nick witkowski says he's grateful to be
back on the field after the unusual
off season making the most of our time
you know
we're finally here we're finally
together so just you know
taking each day you know getting the
most out of it i felt like we did a very
good job during zoom so
over the spring so coming in i don't
feel like there was many hiccups i mean
we hit the ground rolling i mean it's
been a good
first week first couple of days kevin
martin 8 sports now